en un aparente giro el presidente
guatemalteco alejandro giammattei usará
su poder para vetar el proyecto de ley
que condena el aborto y prohíbe el
matrimonio igualitario he decidido que
si esa ley llega a mi despacho la misma
será vetada por lo tanto les recomiendo
el congreso de la república con el
debido respeto que por favor archivo el
decreto 18 2022 viola dos convenciones
de las cuales guatemala es signataria
adolece de deficiencias técnicas en su
redacción pero lo más preocupante es que
viola la constitución política de la
república
ya mate ya había celebrado esta misma
semana la decisión del congreso
asegurando que su país es la capital
probidad e iberoamérica tenemos que
respetar la vida desde su concepción
no hay excusas
para que no podamos cumplir lo que manda
la constitución la constitución política
de la república dice que se protege la
vida desde su concepción
pero más lo creemos aún cuando tenemos
las tres letras y debe ser porque no
sólo es porque lo mande la ley sino
porque lo mandó a nuestra fe 18 el
proyecto de ley que había sido congelado
en 2018 fue reactivado por el partido
conservador viva y aprobado el martes en
pleno día internacional de la mujer
[Música]
la ley busca condenar el aborto hasta
con 25 años de prisión
prohibir el matrimonio entre personas
del mismo sexo así como la enseñanza
sobre la identidad de género